well the fear of judgment is a really
interesting conversation right because
the fear of judgment is usually a
narrative or a story that we create in
our own mind and nothing's actually
happened yet we're usually time
traveling we're going out into the
future think oh what if this happens
what if they think that what if this
this happens it needs to be approached
on a Case by case basis but any decent
therapist will keep 100% confidentiality
I guarantee this to every single person
that I work with unless I ask for
permission to share a testimonial or
something along those lines I will not
share anything if you feel that you're
under there are a lot of pressure in
your work environment right now and you
need space to work on yourself then that
is a moment where I would advise
communicating it to your employer and if
there's somebody who you trust within
that business who you can communicate it
to first in the confidence that they
won't say it to anybody else then that's
the way which I probably approach that
most businesses have a mental health
representative within the business these
days that would be a first part of call
good person to start with that would be
a good person to start with